[Applause]
thank you
welcome to tonight's program in the
beginning said Douglas Adams the
universe was created and this made many
people very angry and is widely regarded
as a bad move now whether or not that's
your view of our universe it was created
we are stuck with it and many of us want
to figure out how it actually began and
that is what the subject of tonight's
program tonight's discussion will be all
about and what I'm going to do here in
just the first few minutes of the
program a kind of prologue if you will
is just give you an overview of the
basic idea is the basic language in our
thinking about the origin of the
universe that will then set us up for
our discussion in which we'll have some
of the leading thinkers the prime movers
the architects of our understanding of
cosmology joining us on the stage and we
will take this initial discussion much
further ok so to understand the origin
of the universe it turns out that you
need to have an understanding of that
force which is most relevant on large
distances cosmic scales that is the
force of gravity so let's begin just by
way of things that I think most of us
are quite familiar with the first
attempt to understand gravity which of
course takes us to this picture here
right it's Isaac Newton late 1600s
writes down the famous universal law of
gravity that we are all familiar with
you can say with me f equals G m1 m2
over R squared thank you and with that
little equation Newton is able to
predict the motion of objects planets
the moon terrestrial objects and the
predictions coming from that little
equation
are borne out by observation which gives
a sense that gravity is now understood
but then something pretty dramatic
happens early part of the 20th century
if you fast forward a new thinker comes
on the scene of physics and this thinker
is unwilling to accept Authority accept
the notion that all issues that had been
viewed as solved by a previous
generation perhaps they need to be
rethought and in this particular case of
course I'm talking about Albert Einstein
and when he focused on Newton's law of
gravity there was kind of a puzzle that
immediately occurred to him which is how
does how does gravity actually exert
that force that we call gravity right if
you have the Sun over here you got the
earth over there there's basically empty
space between them what's the mechanism
by which the Sun affects the Earth's
motion right so this was a deep puzzle
Einstein naturally thought that he
should go back to the writings of Isaac
Newton to get a sense of what he was
thinking about in terms of the mechanism
underlying the force of gravity so he
goes back to the Principia you know all
the results that Newton found during his
lifetime he looks up gravity right you
know letter G finds you know F equals G
m1 m2 over R squared the universal law
of gravity he looks underneath
subheading M for the mechanism by which
gravity operates in there Newton says I
don't know how gravity works in fact in
his own words he said so the answer of
that important question the mechanism by
which gravity operates he said I leave
it to the consideration of the reader
now most readers would read that in read
on right but this is Einstein who's
reading at this moment and he sees this
as a grand challenge to figure out the
underlying mechanism by which gravity is
transmitted from one place to another so
he spends 10 long years trying to figure
it out and finally he comes to an answer
which is kind of the most simple answer
you could imagine in a sense because if
you got the Sun here the earth here if
there's empty space in between them then
somehow it must be space itself that is
the medium for transmitting the force
craft somehow space must be exerting the
force that we usually attribute to
gravity and indeed that is the idea and
here's how it goes so Einstein imagines
here is 3d space kind of grid like image
a little hard to think in full 3d so
let's go to a two-dimensional version
which captures all the ideas and here's
the key idea space is flat if there's
nothing there but according to Einstein
if the Sun appears the fabric of space
curves it warps and in fact if you look
in the vicinity of the earth the earth
curves the environment around it - and
now focus your attention on the moon
because here is the main point the moon
is kept in orbit because it's rolling
along a valley in the curved environment
that the earth creates that is how
gravity works and if you pull back the
earth is kept in orbit for the same
reason rolling along a valley in the
curved environment that the Sun creates
that's the basic idea of Einstein's
general theory of relativity of course
that's an artist's rendition an
animation of the basic ideas there's an
equation underlying this picture to
write the equation that takes the place
of Newton's equations again you can say
it with me right arm you knew minus 1/2
G me nu R cos 8 pi G over C to the
fourth T mu nu right so that is the new
equation of Einstein's general theory of
relativity
Nativity now this is a spectacularly
interesting idea how do you test it how
do you know if it's correct well
Einstein himself realized that if space
actually curves to communicate the force
of gravity then imagine the following
light from distant stars as that light
passes by the Sun the curvature of space
will cause the trajectory of the light
to be curved which means if you look at
distant stars when the Sun is between us
and the star the star light will curve
as I just mentioned but six months later
when the Sun is on the other side the
trajectory of the star light will not
Bend and therefore the position of the
stars in the sky should shift between
those two observations now how can you
see distant stars when the Sun is
between us well you need a solar eclipse
to block out the Sun temporarily making
those distant stars appear so this was
the idea in 1919 two teams of
astronomers go out to measure the
positions of stars during a solar
eclipse to see if they shift and the
manner predicted by Einstein's theory of
general relativity and the amazing thing
is as we see here they found lights are
all askew in the heavens men of science
more or less a goggle results of
eclipses observation Einstein's theory
triumphs stars not where they seem to be
orbit calculated to be but nobody need
worry
Einstein's theory was confirmed through
this prediction giving rise to an
observation that agrees with it story
goes that Einstein received telegram
telling him about these results and he
was asked professor Einstein what would
you have said but you've thought if the
observations didn't agree with the
predictions of general relativity and
Einstein is purported to have said I
would have been sorry for the dear Lord
because the theory is correct now I
don't think that he actually really
would have said that but it shows how
the power of a theoretical idea can
almost in some sense emanate a sense of
truth but ultimately that must be
confirmed by observation now this
results made Einstein famous worldwide
theory attained great fame and that led
people to start to think about using the
general theory of relativity to try to
solve various problems applied in
various ways and this fella over here
Belgian priest Georg lament he took
Einstein's idea his equations and
applied those equations to the entire
universe and found something very
unexpected he found that the math was
showing that the universe couldn't be
static it couldn't be unchanging it had
to either be stretching or contracting
the fabric of space who would be growing
or shrinking over time now this was a
very unfamiliar heretical idea he took
this idea and told Einstein about it
1927 and Einstein said your mathematics
is correct but your physics is
abominable what he meant by that was you
can't believe all mathematics right you
have to have good sense
Einstein was saying you have to know
which mathematics to trust because if it
gives an implication that's manifestly
wrong you can't believe it right I some
is saying he was parroting the
philosophy of the time that on the
largest of scales the universe is static
eternal unchanging you look out there
nothing on the largest of scales is
happening so he just thought this is
wrong now the reason why he said your
math is correct was actually because of
this guy over here Alexander Friedmann
who I should say looks just like an
accountant I used years ago
and in fact right around tax time he
would look at me just like that but
anyway so this is a gender freed Mont
and even earlier even before lumetri he
had also undertaken a similar
calculation shown at Einstein Einstein
at first said your math is wrong but
then he was convinced by Friedman that
Einstein was wrong I um had to retract
that criticism but he never thought I
never thought that the math was telling
us anything about reality and all that
changed with this guy over here Edwin
Hubble Hubble used the powerful
telescope at Mount whistle Observatory
to look at distant galaxies and found
that the galaxies were all rushing away
from us right the universe is expanding
and you know it sounds amazing
you know Hubble was an Oxford trained
lawyer who turned his attention to
astronomy which to me proves there's
hope for absolutely everyone but there
we had it so the data was showing that
the math was right the universe was
expanding of course this gave rise to
the picture
yes the universe is today expanding and
the idea is ever earlier back in time
the universe is smaller and smaller and
smaller until way back in the beginning
it was really small as we just showed
and underwent a rapid swelling that we
are still witnessing the aftermath of
today by seeing those distant galaxies
all rushing away the Big Bang Theory was
born and that of course is a great
triumph but the Big Bang Theory itself
has a number of problems some of which
we are going to focus on in the
discussion in just a few moments but let
me just raise one of them right here
just to give us a sense of where we're
going an unanswered question in the Big
Bang Theory it turns out is well what is
it that drove the outward swelling of
space what force was pushing everything
apart now this is a question that people
struggle with in one form or another for
for many years but thankfully in our age
these gentlemen over here Alan Guth Paul
Stoddard Andrei Linde andreas Albrecht
as well as contributions for many other
scientists came up with an answer to
that question I sort of love this
imagery right here because like if you
compare the right side to the left side
you see that modern cosmologists are so
happy
now what they found and what we're going
to be talking about here tonight is the
inflationary theory what they found is
we're going to discuss is that well
we're used to gravity being an
attractive force pull of thing together
but in the hands of Einstein with
general relativity in the hands of these
gentlemen over here they realized that
if you had a kind of exotic source for
gravity not not the earth of the Sun the
usable usual sources for gravity I
should say instead if you have the
universe being filled with a kind of
energy filling space that energy can
give rise to a repulsive gravity that
pushes everything apart that can fuel
the Big Bang itself that's a beautiful
idea but again how do you test it you
don't believe anything until you can
test it and you can at least according
to certain ways of looking at that we're
going to talk about here tonight test
these ideas the test for this makes use
of the cosmic microwave background
radiation one of the most important
features of the observable universe to
gain insight into the earliest moments
of creation so what is the microwave
background radiation well it's heat left
over from the Big Bang kind of afterglow
of creation now it was calculated by a
number of theorists going back to George
Gamow Alpher Herman others people like
Bob Dicke and Jim people so a number of
theorists calculated that there should
be this heat filling the universe
something like 400 photons and every
cubic centimeter rushing through space
but again that's calculation what about
confirmation what confirmation did come
from these fellows over here Arno
Penzias Robert Wilson working at Bell
Labs New Jersey we're working with a
horn shaped antenna
to communicate with satellites through
radio waves and that they needed to do
is eliminate all sources of interference
so they could perform those calculations
so they got rid of you know radar
interference radio broadcast they cooled
it to get rid of the thermal
interference but still they found a
noise that the detector kept showing
that couldn't get rid of the noise they
even wondered whether the noise might be
coming from bird dropping some birds had
nested in the horns they cleaned out the
bird droppings but still the noise was
there and of course what they found was
the hiss of creation the cosmic
microwave background radiation and
indeed it was 50 years ago this week
that the discovery happened
the two gentlemen won the 1978 Nobel
Prize in Physics and we are honored that
in the audience here tonight is Robert
Wilson you take a stand here
so again it's a beautiful story of
prediction and conformation and I raise
it here this will now lead into our
broader discussion because the
inflationary theory suggests that there
is additional information hidden in that
radiation that could give us insight
into whether the inflationary theory
itself is correct what's the basic idea
we'll come back to it the basic idea is
early universe they're quantum
fluctuations in homogeneity that get
stretched by the rapid swelling of space
coming from this repulsive gravity and
that yields tiny temperature differences
in this radiation sprinkled all across
the sky so the prediction then is that
there is something that looks like this
these little speckles represent slight
temperature variations in space that are
in principle detectable in fact have
been detected let me now show you a
comparison between the theoretical
prediction and the observations so let's
take a quick look here the curve
theoretical predictions for statistical
features of the temperature variations
these now are the observations and I'll
just sort of stand back holy cow
right is your sense that theorists know
what they're doing that we have some
sense of what things were like in the
early universe and we're going to talk a
little bit more about this in the
discussion a moment let me conclude
though with the following final point
which will drive our discussion the
theory claims that there should be even
a more subtle imprint in the microwave
background radiation that might in some
sense be the true final smoking gun at
least according to some for this theory
Hill dissenting voices in the
conversation but some would say that if
we could find the signal about to
describe that would really seal the case
what's the signal I'm talking about
well those quantum
tuition as I was mentioning they also
affect not just stuff in space but space
itself so space itself can undergo
quantum ripples quantum jitters right
now this is at the microscopic scale if
inflation actually happened these guys
would be stretched out into longer
ripples gravitational waves rippling
through the fabric of space and when the
temperature variations in the microwave
back when are laid down these ripples
can have an impact on that relic
radiation giving rise to a swirling
pattern in something known as the
polarization in the microwave background
radiation and in March there was an
announcement that the swirling pattern
had been found and we're going to be
talking about that here tonight
generated much excitement a lot of
controversy we'll try to sort it all out
with some of the great experts on the
planet today all right so let's bring
them on our first guests groundbreaking
discovery of the inflationary theory
changed the game on how we look at the
Big Bang
and we've all been playing on his field
ever since the prime mover in our modern
understanding of cosmology Alan Guth
our next guests took Alan goose
discoveries a step further when he
proposed a new version of inflation even
suggested that our universe might not be
the only universe one of the most
influential cosmologists in the last
thirty years
please welcome Andrei Linde along with
Alan Guth and Andrei Linde our next
guest is one of the architects of the
inflationary model he also has developed
alternative models motivated in part by
issues that he has identified with the
inflationary theory please welcome from
Princeton University Paul Steinhardt our
next guest leads Columbia University's
experimental cosmology group and has had
great impact on understanding of the
microwave background radiation please
welcome the first dean of science of
Columbia University professor of physics
amber Miller all right at our final
guests for two decades has been
designing deploying and operating
telescopes at the South Pole and one of
them may have found evidence confirming
how the universe began certainly has
ignited a spirited discussion on the Big
Bang and inflation please welcome from
Harvard University
John Colvin all right so talking a
moment we're going to talk about what it
is that you announced in March but just
to set a little bit of context I just
want to get really quick thoughts on how
important the discovery of say these
ripples in the fabric of space from the
Big Bang would be so amber fellow
observer of the universe how exciting
would it be to confirm that these
ripples in the fabric of space have been
found Carrie all right good good science
right Allen thoughts on that from a
theoretical perspective well I agree
very important in particular it is very
strong confirmation that inflation took
place it also allows us to determine for
the first time the rate of expansion of
the universe at the time of inflation
which is a very important number which
we otherwise don't know now Andre we
sort of know what your reaction is
because there's this viral YouTube video
which caught your reaction when you
first heard this news I almost don't
have to ask you but exciting it would be
it is one of the confirmations of
general theory of relativity at quantum
level so it is a next stage it's not
just a general theory of relativity but
it's quantization and the energies which
are spectacular larger than energies
which can be reached the highest of all
the most powerful accelerators on the
earth right now a Paul you know I know
that you have somewhat differing views
on the inflationary theory today and
we're going to come to that but putting
that aside for a moment just the actual
observation of gravitational waves from
the beginning of the universe scale one
to ten how cool would it be Oh a hundred
hundred there we go be extraordinarily
important I don't think we can you jump
to the conclusion that it's a comes from
inflation yeah I think that's something
that that needs to be proven I think
there are various possible sources of
gravitational ways including things that
we might not get of thought of so but it
will be it would be an extraordinary
gift that Nature gave us a cosmic signal
that Nature gave us that will eventually
enable us to determine what no where the
history of the universe originated from
where we're going yep absolutely a very
important all right so with that sort of
as the context of the importance let's
turn to John Kovac and just want to get
a sense of the experiment and and what
you found so even just to set what it's
like how many people work on bicep2
which is the name of the experiment so
we've had a very talented team about 45
people of that order working at
different institutions lead institutions
Caltech Stanford the University of
Minnesota my own institution Harvard a
lot of the people young people students
and postdocs have really dedicated their
careers to this and this telescope
see a picture of it here it's a very
it's a very unusual and very
custom-built telescope it's good really
doing one thing measuring the
polarization of the Cosmic Microwave
Background on the specific angular
scales in which this theory predicts
that gravitational waves would arise and
it's a it's a crazy outlandish theory
from an experimentalist point of view
that we could imagine what's happening
at energies so extreme and times so
early so the idea that this theory gives
us a target something that we can build
a machine to go out there and look for
and see whether it's there or not
motivates you know my team motivates
lots of teams that are doing similar
work right I'm asking a second to
explain some of the terms that that you
used and I've been using gravitational
waves polarization but what did you find
in fact I think we can even show the
graph one of the key graphs from your
paper right so that's it huh
that's it yeah and compare it to the
graph that you showed just a minute ago
of the beautiful measurements so that
the temperature speckles across the sky
and how they match up in the theoretical
curve you can see the the the level of
the data at this stage that we've
extract so the so the bump in that curve
is the bump in the curve the the excess
of the points the black data points yep
above the red curve which is below there
shows the excess of this swirling
pattern in that map above the simplest
expectation so can we see the swirling
again just to have that picture in mind
I think it's C that's right so this is
actually slightly different colors than
you're used to but the same the same
yeah same swirls yep so so those swirls
are indicating the polarization that
you're talking about and it comes from
gravitational waves that have an impact
when the CMB is formed a few hundred
thousand years after the Big Bang so can
you just give us a quick explanation of
what polarization is just so that we all
know we're talking about
so light as I'm sure the whole audience
knows is is a it's both a particle and a
wave phenomenon so if we think of it as
a wave phenomenon it's a disturbance
that's in the electric and magnetic
fields so as light propagates in a
direction the electric field might be
aligned in a particular orientation with
respect to the way that that light is
coming I think we have a little visual
can you bring up the polarization video
just to write so this is what you're
talking about so an electromagnetic wave
light and right here we see the the
light coming towards the side of the
screen and imagine the electric field is
represented by the red here and the
amplitude of that field is oscillating
up and down on a vertical plane so a
light wave likes being animated here
would be described as a hundred percent
polarized completely polarized in the
vertical direction so if we go back to
the map what we're actually seeing with
our telescope is very small degrees of
polarization of this early that this
light that's coming to us microwave
light from the sky the the patterns that
we see in this map at each point express
the degree of polarization that's coming
to a polarization of the light coming to
us from that spot on the sky so when you
see a vertical bar on that map that
actually represents not a
hundred-percent polarization of the
light but a polarization at the level of
typically one part in 30 million ones Oh
thirteen if you think of particles of
light photons coming to us from that
spot in the sky what that means is for
every 30 million photons that are coming
to us with a horizontal orientation that
field you might see 30 million in one on
average coming with the vertical
orientation extremely faint effects so
you need to build a very specialized
telescope to be able to teach the size
and and the the origin of that
polarization that tiny polarization that
you're talking about may have come from
gravitational waves that originated with
in some sense the Big Bang so just
quickly gravitational waves I mentioned
it briefly my introductory remarks I
think we have a little image of it if
you can just explain what that is and
what a gravitational wave would do sure
so a gravitational wow that's a wrong
gravitational wave let's hold on so a
gravitational wave not nearly that
strong passing through the early
universe that arises according to this
theory of inflation that we've been that
we've been given has the potential to
distort space-time in the early universe
when these microwave photons are being
released and that distortion of
space-time can be thought of as a
stretching and a compression and that
can impart a particular polarization to
the light that comes to us from that
region in space and the geometry of the
stretching and compression of a
gravitational wave can actually impart a
specific swirling pattern to the
polarized light as we look at it across
the sky that kind of swirling pattern
isn't expected to arise from the the
other well-known physics that produces
polarization of the Cosmic Microwave
Background light so how long did it take
you to find the state to accumulate this
data so the data that you see behind you
was collected by the bicep2 team over
three years of relentless observations
from the South Pole training our
telescope on a small patch of sky and
you're down there like doing this oh
you're like hey turn on the telescope
when I was a young student that actually
did spend an entire year at the South
Pole threw one winner one winner was
enough for me yeah but we go down there
in the summer months three months of the
year you can get in and out of the South
Pole Station the National Science
Foundation flies us in and out on ski
equipped c-130s it's really an amazing
adventure and then when the last plane
leaves in February we leave behind a
small crew and typically one person
running each telescope and that person
will operate the telescope for the next
nine months and we have that telescope
trained on that patch of sky collecting
as many of those photons as possible
because you need an awful lot of them to
tease out those really early small
effects so three years of data went into
that map all right fantastic so the
excitement when you made this
announcement in March was largely tied
to the inflationary theory which
suggests that this is the kind of result
that you'd expect if the inflation
theory is right so I'd like to now place
it in context and head back to the
discovery of the inflationary theory so
Alan I'm going to start with you you you
know had a fantastic great breakthrough
in the late 1970s and I just want to
sort of briefly walk through it so first
off in the 1970s what was the state of
Big Bang cosmology what were the
essential problems and they're actually
two that I'd like you to focus on the
flatness problem the horizon problem if
you just tell us what those are the
flatness problem is something that I in
fact just learned about almost by
coincidence at a lecture I dropped in on
given by Bob Dicke from Princeton this
problem that has to do with the
fine-tuning of the expansion rate of the
early universe as Bob Dicke explained it
that expansion rate if you think for
example of the universe at a time of one
second after the instant of creation
that expansion rate had to be just right
to an accuracy of about 14 decimal
places if it was expanding just a little
bit faster by one digit and the
fourteenth definite place the universe
would have swung apart so fast that
galaxies would never have a chance to
form and if was expanding just a little
bit slower again just by one digit in
the fourteenth decimal place the
universe would have rapidly we collapsed
before any galaxies or structures could
form and within the conventional Big
Bang Theory there was nothing that
explained why the expansion rate was
what it had to be it just had to be that
or else the universe would not look
anything like what it does look like and
presumably we would not be here yep
that's the flatness problem the horizon
problem has to do with the uniformity of
the observed universe no we're not that
used to thinking of the universe as
being that uniform we see clumps of
galaxies and galaxy clusters but if you
averaged over larger scales the universe
starts to look amazingly uniform and
this uniformity is most striking in the
cosmic background radiation
astronomers have now very carefully
measured the temperature pattern and
we've seen fluctuations which we've seen
Maps up on the screen here but
nonetheless the temperature is in fact
uniform to one part in 100
those maps describe very very small
fluctuations to men dysley exaggerated
so the question is how did the universe
get to be so uniform and so uniform so
early this cosmic background radiation
was released at about 400,000 years
after the instant of creation so you can
imagine that somehow things smooth
themselves out but when you try to
calculate you soon realize that within
the parameters of the conventional Big
Bang Theory that's simply not possible
in particular you can imagine tracing
back the photons coming from that
direction in the sky and similarly to
trace back the photons coming from the
opposite direction and when you do that
calculation you find that at the time of
emission those two sources were
separated from each other by about a
hundred times the distance that life
could have traveled up until that time
and that means that there's no way that
that photon could have known anything
about that photon yet somehow they
arranged to have the same temperature to
an accuracy of one part 100,000 and
nobody had the foggiest idea how that
could happen and that was the horizon
problem so at the risk of this sounding
like a seder what was special about the
night number 6 1979 it was certain the
climax of about a year of my working on
this very much influenced by a fellow
postdoc at Cornell at the time Henry Tai
who's the first person who got me into
this in the first place really we were
looking at the question of suppression
of magnetic monopole production which I
won't want to get into now but in any
case we were dealing with I pollicis
that the universe underwent a tremendous
amount of super cooling at a phase
transition that certain particle
theories predicted would have taken
place in the early universe and I went
home that night and answered a question
which Henry had raised actually which is
what effect would this super cooling
have on the expansion rate of the
and once you write down those equations
the answer is actually pretty obvious it
has a tremendous effect on the expansion
of the universe it drives the universe
into this phase of exponential expansion
which we now call inflation so this was
in your own words a spectacular
realization yeah amazing thing you know
there's all this you know talk about the
NSA and you know sometimes you know it's
good stuff
we actually got a hold hope you don't
mind of they had footage of a nanny cam
that you had said I don't mind you bring
up the footage so there you are
I just wonder did you think it was a
breakthrough when like the equation
started floating that's always on like
when your pen started you know drifting
you know the universe is really
expanding all it was that that's sort of
that's what that's what it's like yeah
yeah so so this was you know an amazing
moment and we actually having a shot of
your notebook if we can bring that up on
the screen so there we have it
right spectacular realization yeah
that's really all unlike the previous
film yeah no no I should say the other
another film was not real um it's from
from a nova program but so there there
is what you found and I just want to go
a little bit more deeply into what it is
that you found so you said the universe
supercooled so basically if I understand
correctly and I'm just gonna move us
along here there is a field that you
hypothesize which is kind of a substance
that fills space and the idea was that
the field was occupying a certain value
that was giving an energy that would
fill space in fact the energy was such
that it could drive this acceleration
this outward expansion of space so if we
can just show a little picture maybe you
can just describe if this is a good
description of as I can bring that up so
what are we seeing right here okay what
we're sitting here is a graph where the
horizontal axis is the value of this
scalar field that we're studying or how
prophesizing and the vertical axis is
the energy density that space would have
if the field had that value value on the
horizontal axis and we really believe
that there are very likely scalar fields
in nature which behave this way the
Higgs field that the standard model
looks something like that so what the
little ball shows is the possibility
that the scalar field could have the
value at the bottom of that hill and if
it did classically it would stay there
forever
because it can never have enough energy
to get over the hill to get to the lower
energy quantum mechanical you can tunnel
can tunnel through the barrier I think
we can show us this guy there goes right
through the barrier so when it turns
through then that would be the end
against inflation so we just just see it
again so the process would be then
something like this the fields hanging
out at that value and then it tunnels
through and that happens very quickly
and that's the end of this rapid phase
of expansion of the early universe good
so you know just to sort of see this in
a little bit more detail those of you
who don't like equations can't ignore
this but so this is the basic math
behind this right so what's that
equation we're looking at up there
that's one of the famous equations
derived by Alexander Friedmann in 1922
and if maybe 24 and if what we have on
the right hand side if if the energy
density and the pressure satisfy that
relation then then what happens is a
double dot which represents the
acceleration of the expansion change the
sign normally it's positive normally
that equation is dominated by the first
term there which is the Greek letter Rho
which means mass density but if the
pressure is negative which it is for
this peculiar state then that quantity
Rho plus 3 P over C squared becomes
negative and the force of gravity is
reversed it magically becomes repulsive
instead of attractive and that gives us
a solution is equation that any
undergraduate or high school kid could
work out where the expansion goes faster
and faster over time and that then gives
rise to the bang so that's the way we
want to
think about that okay so this was the
beginning of the inflationary theory
let's just quickly describe for us how
to solve the problems that you started
off with for why we would look for an
alternate theory at all so how does this
address the flatness problem okay well
there you have some video some some
stills that might be useful okay he
didn't show me these in advance
especially because this came from your
book okay but there are multiple
explanations some of which are not in my
book okay welcome to the one from my
book the equations of general relativity
themselves which we haven't written
entirely here link this expansion rate
to the curvature of the universe and the
prediction from inflation is that the
expansion rate is going to be just the
right rate to correspond to a flat
universe and given that it's now pretty
obvious to see what this next picture is
gonna be the sphere is going to get
bigger and bigger which is what
inflation does assume we're gonna have
that and as it gets bigger and bigger or
if you look at a fixed size of the image
it gets to look flatter and flatter so
it's just like the basic reason why the
surface of the earth looks flat to us
even though we know perfectly well these
days that the earth is actually round
but as long as you look at a small patch
of it it looks flat and for the same
reason our patch of universe looks flat
to us because we're basically looking
for at a very small part of something
which on a much larger scale may be
curved we really don't know okay for
horizon problem we have another little
image over here which basically just
sets up the problem you're talking about
two distant regions in the universe
having temperatures that were very very
close but if they try to communicate by
sending a signal between them you said
that if a photon starts to travel say
from the patch on the left and it's
traveling outward doesn't have enough
time to reach the region way over there
how therefore till they correlate their
temperatures how does inflation address
that problem basically idea is very
simple
inflation inserts into the scenario of
the universe a period of gigantic
expansion
which is just not there in the
conventional model without inflation and
that means that if you imagine thinking
about the region of the universe that we
see today and tracing it backwards in
time when it goes through this period of
inflation it's now contracting rather
than expanding this we're following it
backwards it means that before inflation
the region was vastly smaller than we
ever would have thought in the context
of conventional cosmology and that means
that before inflation there's plenty of
time for the universe to smooth out
those in density and temperature in
exactly the same way as the air in the
room smoothes itself out across the
lecture hall acquiring an approximately
constant temperature constant density
those guys are so close that it's easy
for them to communicate early on and
then then you put and emotion takes over
yep and magnifies this tiny region to
become large enough to include
everything that we currently see so
that's the basic idea and just quickly
the aftermath of this discovery so
here's your paper okay describe this and
then we have also here a cool little
magazine article Copernicus Galileo
Hubble and now Guth I love that right
what was that like
so this changed everything yeah no it
certainly changed everything from my
career at before the discovery inflation
I had been a postdoc for nine years at
four different places and I had a job
for one more year after that that had
been lined up but beyond that who knew
yep and something I was getting offers
from all over the full story is that I
got an offer from essentially all over
accept from MIT which is where I wanted
to be I had been a graduate student
there and liked it so I finally actually
on the advice of a fortune cookie to
call him IT and ask if maybe maybe
they'd be interested hiring me too since
that's of other places seen today and
they said yes and I went to MIT and
they've been there ever since wow I
didn't know that story it's fantastic
all right so Andre and Paul in Alan's
original version of inflation all these
good things happen but they're even Alan
had pointed out that there was some some
issues and that's when both of you come
into the story what was the main issue
that needed to be addressed to make this
theory fly as far as one would like it
to yeah well one can explain it in the
following way in Alan's theory the skill
field seats in the minimum over the
potential and does not move so this
looks like exactly like an empty space
and when you are talking about empty
space then the question is how do you
even know that this empty space expands
because there is nothing there so the
notion of expansion becomes kind of
questionable on the form of level this
means that there is no preferable
coordinate system and in some system
actually the universe collapses and then
it expands and then when it decays when
a tunnels it tunnels in different
regions totally inherently and as a
result even though the idea how
inflation exponential expansion smooth
as the universe you need to explain what
it's smooth it if it's already smooth if
it's vacuum and how it decays
simultaneously everywhere so the same
problem of simultaneous decay requires
some marks on what expands to say that
it is simultaneous so this is the basic
reason why you have a problem with this
simply so what it say you came up with a
way of addressing this yeah it was
actually it was like that you know you
have this minimum like Allen and then
the question was do you really tunnel
directly to the absolute minimum or not
and at that time I was just running my
computer and checking how it goes and I
have seen that actually sometimes you're
tunneling almost horizontally and then
for wool for a long time you are rolling
down and then when you are rolling down
then the universe continued expanding
almost exponentially somewhat like we're
saying here yeah
can we run that one again right rather
than having it sitting in some yeah
little minimum you're imagining a shape
more like this yes and that addresses
the issues all right and at that time
when I first realized that this is
possible I thought that maybe I'm just
dreaming making a mistake because it
could not be real so a cold at night and
this was in summer 81 I counted at night
one of my colleagues and I asked him we
whether you thought about anything like
that and because I was afraid to wake up
my family I was colleague sitting at
night in the restroom with the telephone
calling so had to wake up the children
and I asked him and he said nope I
didn't think about it I say oh well then
I hang up and they waked up my wife and
totally I know how the universe was born
[Laughter]
so Paul you also were inspired to work
on inflationary ideas around the same
time what did you find something similar
to this in mind yeah well first of all I
should say that the whole reason why I
entered cosmology was because I was
privileged to hear a talk by Alan one of
the first talks he gave on inflationary
cosmology I walked in the room as a as a
young postdoc never having taken a
course on cosmology never having studied
it but in the course of one hour I was
converted it was I always described it
as the most inspiring and most
depressing talk I ever heard because for
most the talk Alan was telling this
wonderful story just how he described
how there were these fundamental
problems to be solved and and and how
inflation could potentially solve them
but then in the very last five minutes
of the talk he explained how the idea
failed that although you managed to get
the field trapped in this minimum that
you did that was shown there although
would occasionally tunnel
it would only tunnel out in a tiny
region a tiny bubble of empty space
nothing that would contain the stars and
galaxies that we would see and that
occasionally maybe these bubbles would
collide but that would not lead produce
enough stuff to make the universe that
we observed so he began the solution of
the problem but there was a sticking
point how do you ever end this inflation
in a what we now call a graceful way in
a smooth way that leaves a universe
which is filled with the matter and
radiation that we see so I remember
sitting in the room after everyone I
just was stunned by this talk I just sat
and I think I was like the third or
fourth row back and everyone was leaving
and I was just thinking oh there's got
to be a solution to this problem this is
too sweet an idea to let's us stand
there so so I thought well I'll spend a
few weeks working on you know learning a
little bit of cosmology and doing this
and I can go back to what I normally do
but in fact they haven't stopped working
on cosmology ever since and I guess my
inspiration was I was trying to look for
different solutions to get around this
problem of getting caught by this energy
barrier and the process of reading about
phase transitions supercooling I've
discovered there was a different kind of
phase transition that people that was
not so well known certainly not in the
highness
G or cosmology community which isn't the
kind that occurs by this tunneling but
it's what's called Aspen nodal
transition has a technical name it's
known in the metallurgy literature quite
a bit but it was not known in in even
most condensed matter physicists don't
know if that thoroughly and and that
turns out to be a picture in which the
phase transition occurs that in such a
way that as you supercool the barrier
disappears and you can end up with this
flat plateau that we saw here and that
was the I swear the idea came from that
there was this alternative phase
transition I have to say that III was
not quite as excited as Andre was when I
when I made this so you weren't in the
bathroom when you did in the bathroom
but there was there was there was a
feature there was a feature that
bothered me then and continues to bother
me now which is to have this special
kind of phase transition you have to
tune the parameters in the theory rather
specially so your goal is to explain
naturally why certain things occur but
you're doing it at a price of arranging
this phase transition sort of dialing
the knobs that make that curve it's just
so away and that's one of the problems
that remains with us today now Andre
you've thought about this this problem
of Tony you've you have argued that
they're more general shapes that can
still give rise to inflation and so tell
us a little bit about chaotic inflation
well that was a continuation of the
story so this was a first Allen's model
than our model of new inflation and then
this model of new inflation survived for
about a year and then we had some
problem even with this new model and the
problem was well with many different
aspects of it but it stamped in
particular from our assumption that
first there was this hot Big Bang then
were these phase transitions then there
was a super cooling the end of this
tunneling etc and all of this set of
things it was very difficult to much
together and what happened later is that
I realized that you don't necessarily
need it
because instead of all of these strange
potential withstanding etcetera
you can just have simplest parabolic
potential and then the scale yeah right
oh my god well so the scalar field in
these potential and interestingly in
normal kind of previously studied models
where the field stuck and the minimum
for a while then here there's maybe not
even minimum you may have it temporarily
does not matter and you may not need any
phase transitions and supercooling
anything but what happens is that when
you are solving Einstein equations
together with the equation for the
scalar field and explaining universe you
find out that there is a strong friction
which stops the field from rapidly
running down it's like the universe
helps the scalar field
please stay here for a while no no I
want to go down please stay here forever
so when the scalar fields a base then it
stays for a while at approximately the
same height without any need to some
support like that just like that on the
wall and during this time because the
amplitude of the scalar field almost
does not change then the universe
expands almost exponentially now this
thing almost doesn't change is extremely
important if the shape of the potential
such that it's very very curved no
inflation rolls down too fast if it is
very very flat there is an opposite
danger the speed of the motion of the
field becomes very slow like in the
original model way just totally flat and
then what happens is that perturbations
of density which wait just a moment in
the beginning they are too large so you
must be just the golden medium between
that not too steep not the flat just
right then the universe gives you well
galaxies which you want to do them now
another feature which which both it I
think all of you have played a part in
is that we have these models of
inflation so you've got this field
filling space energy is giving rise to
this repulsive gravity pushing
everything apart but it's very hard to
get it to fully end
which suggests that there may be other
realms other regions that are undergoing
this expansion to which in poetic
language can be spoken of as other
universes so tell anybody wants to jump
in on that one well I can say a little
just using this one potential which
shown here so naturally you would expect
that this is what you go you just go
down you go down you go down straight
forward but you'll notice that maybe you
can hear it again you see that potential
you know she notices that this dot was
jumping here so what this jump means
well during expansion of the universe
there are tiny tiny quantum fluctuations
of the skill field they are tiny but the
universe expands them and then the
universe expands new quantum
fluctuations are produced and a new
quantification sometimes not always not
everywhere this quantifications bring
the scale field upwards again and then
the universe expands scale Hill Goes
Down and in some places it is brought
back again and when it happens in those
parts of the universe where the scalar
field jumps back again the speed of
expansion becomes as large as it was
initially and then this part becomes
separate exponential large part of the
universe so it looks like the universe
self reproduces itself this is like if
you think about what Greeks told us here
is our universe and this is perfect
sphere at least we'll try to understand
why it is perfect so now that we
understood that it is perfect this
quantum fluctuations make it slightly
imperfect and it's like imperfections
sometimes produce galaxies as we will
learn later and sometimes it produces
new pieces of the universe which are
also expanding and the universe becomes
a fractal so it is eternally growing
fractal tree consisting of new universes
and new universes producing like we have
a little bit in that can you skip ahead
to the eternal inflation video just to
give a sense of what the universe would
look like that'd be a single Big Bang
that's the decay of the inflation in one
place so each of these bubbles here
floating in this background of Lin
photon field would be one of the
universes that you're talking about with
our universe just being one in this big
vast collection so that's the place that
we've gotten to with these ideas of
inflation and to bring in the observers
as I'd like to do in a moment I want to
turn now to the evidence that we have
for these ideas where the argument
usually comes from the microwave
background radiation and these
fluctuations so I want to turn to it
just a quick discussion of that all of
you guys have had a hand in this Allen
and Paul I think there was this famous
workshop right what was it called enough
field workers have a definite one so
tell us what was going on there okay
this was the summer of 1982 shortly
after this new inflationary model is
invented by Andhra and Paul and Andy
Albrecht and people were beginning to
think about the question of how uniform
should the universe be and for a while a
number of us were very worried that
inflation because it just stretches
everything to make it smooth we produce
a universe that would be completely
smooth and if it started out completely
smooth there'd really be no way that
galaxies perform so eventually the idea
started circulating around the community
in my local group that kind of started
with Stephen Hawking although I later
learned the idea goes all the way back
to Andrei Sakharov much earlier but the
idea was that maybe quantum theory can
be responsible for these fluctuations
and at first that idea sounds very weird
because we always think of quantum
theory is describing things that are
very very small now we're trying to
describe the Galactic structure of the
universe but nonetheless when you think
about it carefully
it certainly initially had the germ of
working because sensation has this
wonderful property of stretching these
tiny quantum fluctuations from very
small scales to bring them up to
macroscopic and cosmological scales and
at this Nuffield workshop
was for different groups I guess were
working on the question of how to
actually calculate these density
perturbations and that the beginning of
the conference I think maybe stair Vince
key knew the right answer the rest of us
didn't but during the course of the
conference we gradually came up with
answers compared them a lot of them
disagreed with each other we were
arguing like mad for it was a three-week
conference but finally by the end we all
agreed on the picture and then we all
published our separate papers with
basically the same conclusions and all
you were you're oh yeah our group was
one of them we were trying to use a
method a special method that was
developed by Jim bar Dean of what's
called a gauge invariant method and
there was an important contribution
because I think it was the the method
that's the most reliable sure method of
doing a calculation in general
relativity there's this subtlety that
when you're looking for a lump or an
excess your the question we're trying to
address is where are there lumps of
energy or lumps and temperature yep and
just distinguishing that from simply a
course of coordinates it reach a
different choice of coordinates and
general relativity is a is a difficult
mathematical challenge that it was
solved by Jim and and having that
powerful method and have all having that
method get the same results and converge
with these other results to give the
same numerical answer I think made us
all really excited at the end of the
conference that we had actually nailed
the question that we came into the
conference worrying that the quantum
fluctuations could destroy the
inflationary theory it could be that you
did the calculation found the quantum
fluctuations and found that they gave us
variation with space that was
incompatible with things we knew instead
what we found was something in between
we found that the initial models that we
were thinking of had the right shapes of
hot spots and cold spots but the
amplitudes the degree of hotness and
coldness was way too strong and but by
the end of the meeting once we
understood how this mechanism worked for
producing the fluctuations we knew what
to do we knew how to change those
inflationary potentials to inflate
change it in order to now makes it
which would give them not only the right
number of hot spots and cold spots not
just the right distribution but also the
degree of hotness and coldness it came
at a price again that we have to still
live with today which is you again
needed to do even more additional
fine-tuning of the parameters than
before so even Andres favorite model of
that cut potential has to be super
fine-tuned by 15 orders of magnitude in
order to we're going to come back come
back
don't answer just now we have something
to look for right so you guys have now
made predictions and thank you he's
never done that so amber so now now
there's something to look for and just
give it a sense before these ideas what
was the state of observational cosmology
and people sort of know what to look for
is this sort of a turning point now
there's something to shoot for well
before inflation you still we still have
this idea of the hot Big Bang YUM
so there is something to look for there
so the idea is if the universe started
hot and dense however we got to the hot
and dense point if it started hot and
dense we should see this Cosmic
Microwave Background so that's what
Brian was talking about at the beginning
where Penzias and Wilson discovered that
there is in fact the Cosmic Microwave
Background that had been predicted in
advance and then following that initial
discovery the COBE satellite then
demonstrated that not only was the hot
Big Bang correct but in fact the
statistical properties of what you would
expect to see in that data were also
correct and in particular the hot plasma
emits as a what is called a blackbody
it's a type of emission that depends
only on the temperature of the plasma so
it's an enormous ly simple system it's
not difficult and you can go and predict
what you should see and you can measure
it and it turned out that what Kobe
measured was that the prediction and the
measurement were so close to each other
that if you draw the theoretical curve
and you plot the data on top of the
theoretical curve unlike the data that
Brian
for the fluctuations that temperature
alone you can't even tell the difference
between the theoretical curve and the
actual measurement so this was this was
the first spectacular demonstration
right track so that that was spectacular
discover the next step then it did look
for the fluctuations and how do you how
do you how do you do that you go out and
you observe the Cosmic Microwave
Background and at every step here we're
just trying to get better at doing that
so we're trying to measure it more
precisely and the game is that you're
always trying to develop the latest
technology you're pushing the boundaries
this is a hard thing to do so you need
very sensitive instruments you need very
well controlled instruments so it isn't
just about raw sensitivity you need to
design your instruments so the signal
that you see you're really really sure
it didn't originate in your instrument
so that's a really important point that
sometimes you get lost when you're
talking about this instruments really
really need to be very specially
designed and then the other thing you
worry about is you want to make sure
that when you're observing what you
think is the Cosmic Microwave Background
you're indeed observing the Cosmic
Microwave Background you're not
observing something that lives in our
galaxy or between our galaxy and the
microwave background remember that when
you're observing the microwave
background you're observing universe as
it was when it was only 380,000 years
old which means that the light was
traveling throughout the entire history
of the universe until it crashes into
your detectors so if it came through
anything else that could have changed
the character or if anything between the
microwave background and your detectors
is itself emitting it can complicate
that signal fortunately there are clever
ways that you can design your
instruments to tell the difference
between the signal in the front and the
signal in the back but you have to do
that right - so the game is to design
these instruments precisely and now
analyze your data very carefully so that
you're sure that what you're seeing is
what you think you're seeing which are
seeing in the background in these
pictures is another approach so there
are three primary approaches to
measuring the Cosmic Microwave
Background there are the ground-based
telescopes like the ones that John was
talking about there are balloon born
experiments like the one you see here
they're the satellites you saw a picture
of minute ago both Kobe and W map
satellites and sometimes for the gold
standard they are very expensive you
don't get to fly them all the time the
other issue with satellites though is
that you have to lock in the technology
are gonna fly in a satellite years
before the satellite actually launches
and the technology development has been
proceeding so quickly and for
ground-based experiments and balloon
borne experiments part of the game is
you grab that technology when it is hot
off the press or you're involved in
developing it and testing it and then
you're allowed in a balloon board an
experiment or a ground-based experiment
to put the technology on the experiment
and try it whereas the satellite you
have to be much more careful so the main
difference between balloon borne and
ground-based experiments as I discovered
when I was a graduate student is if
you're really saying you will choose to
work on a ground-based experiment so
I've naturally in the last several years
been working on a balloon for an
experiment instead if you're really
brave you were gonna blow that's kind so
the the goal of working on a Bloomberg
experiment other than being not sane
this is my experiment called ebox being
launched roughly a year ago also from
Antarctica so an article's the magic
place to do this in in John's case
because it's a really great place to
observe in our case because it's a
really place great place to get up over
the atmosphere so these balloons fly and
about 130,000 feet the reason to fly
from Antarctica is not that there's
anything special about the location per
se but that is the only place in the
world where you're allowed to go and fly
for a long time and the winds are
circumpolar near the poles you could do
this in principle in the north but
Russia doesn't like it when the u.s.
flies equipment I can't imagine why
they'd have a problem with that so in
Antarctica you're allowed to do this so
you also get down on the plains with the
skis and and do something crazy like
build your experiment and then this
thing you've been working on for five to
seven years the folks and
NASA say okay science team hands off
your heart goes into your throat and you
know that all the stuff that on the
ground that you could fix when when not
if when it breaks you don't get to fix
it right so this is why it's insane to
do this the reason one would do it even
though it's insane is that you can
observe it frequencies that are very
difficult to observe at from the ground
so on the ground the atmosphere is
transparent in some frequency bands or
relatively transparent and not all
frequency bands and if you want to
discriminate between emission from
something like dust in our own galaxy
and microwave background radiation it's
nice to be able to measure at a
frequency where dust is the stronger
thing that you expect to see as well as
measure at a frequency where the
microwave background is the thing that
is the strongest thing you expect to see
compare those two signals and then you
can subtract the dust and that's
something you can do from a balloon much
more easily than you can do from the
ground so when you put it all together
through all these wondrous devices
satellites balloon ground-based
telescopes the relationship between the
fluctuations predicted and the
fluctuations measured how closely do
they match you showed the data so here
this is temperature flexure yes if this
is actually just sort of a schematic why
don't we actually move forward to the
actual real graph right there
so just what are we seeing here so this
is a what's called an angular power
spectrum but really you can think of it
as how much fluctuation power you see on
that map of fluctuations as you look at
different characteristic scales so if
you think of blobs of a big blobs how
much big blob this you see is measured
by what you see at the far left and as
you go to characteristic separations
between smaller and smaller and smaller
scale fluctuations you move over there
toward the right the green curve is the
theoretical prediction and the red curve
is what the data actually
measures and what's interesting if you
look down the theoretical predictions
very precise on smaller scales and it's
not so precise on the larger scale
there's some uncertainty and that has to
do with the fact that we only have one
universe to observe so if you're trying
to characterize what you would predict
from the very largest scales you don't
have enough even theoretical information
to be able to say what exactly it should
look like on the very largest scales so
that it's called cosmic variance it's
just something we we cannot measure more
than that the bottom line is a pretty
impressive agreement between spectacular
and that's John now where you come in so
this is the temperature fluctuations you
go one step further and just remind us
again just so we can see the next data
just remind us of you can put the swirly
data back on if you will so this is the
experiment where you're not just looking
at temperature variations but this more
subtle signature the polarization the
vibrational direction of the light right
that's so at different spots in the sky
different blobs different characteristic
scales you're not just counting up how
many more photons you see in that patch
versus that you're measuring the
alignment of the electric field and
you're counting up whether you see an
excess of one alignment over the other
that's what these these lines on this
map represents we map out a patch of the
sky and in this case it's a small patch
of the sky about 1% of the sky and we
tease out the pattern of these
alignments across that patch so this
basically takes us up to March 17 2014
right so we've marched through the
theory the observations and it seems
like a pretty strong story but now we
want to move on to the next chapter of
our discussion here where we're going to
examine the case a little bit more
closely for the for the remainder of the
time that we have here and Paul I want
to now give you time to speak your mind
on why don't we start with with the
observation so there's been a lot of
discussion in in the community and be
good to just have a friendly discussion
out here of are we certain that the
polarization is
have been found are originating with the
creation event inflationary expansion or
could it be something else of Paul
thoughts on that and then John let you
answer of course good actually
I'd like to hear John's answer first
because there has been a lot of
discussion and I don't know what the
current answer is but does want me just
raise the issue because I don't know
that every if you guys listen to the
physics conversation probably not that
my I can I can put on the table just to
help your discussion what the issue is
and then you can pick it up from there
because I just I just don't know what
the bicep2 groups view is on things and
they you should be speaking for that so
the issue has been Jessica issue that
amber brought up we want to make sure
that the signal we're seeing that the
swirly pattern is really due to
something that's happening in the most
distant parts of the universe the Cosmic
Microwave Background and not due to say
to the effects of lensing of galaxies in
the foreground or dust in our own galaxy
or effects in the atmosphere or even
effects in the telescope which can mix
which can turn a pattern which has no
and any one of those things can take
patterns which have no swirls and turn
them into a swirling pattern so you you
know part of the challenge of the team
that they work really hard to do is to
make sure they can't you know they've
really checked all those effects and you
know they're just beginning to roll out
their data and their analysis and there
isn't it I haven't seen you know I
haven't seen for example a systematics
paper that helps us analyze similars
effects but one of the effects that can
be analyzed from the outside is
partially is you know the degree which
dust would contribute a b-mode signal of
its own
Swilly signal of its own and so people
have tried to use different kinds of
data and different kinds of models of
dust to estimate what that so-called
foreground that dust foreground would be
and and so did the bicep2 team try to do
the same but the results disagree i
think that you know the results of group
at Princeton led by Raphael flogger for
example looking at all the desk models
same dust models that they that the that
the bicep2 team used in their analysis
concludes that actually you could
account for most or perhaps all of the
signals that they've observed in this in
terms of swirly patterns not due to
anything to do with the microwave
background not due to anything to do
with gravitational waves but might be
due entirely to dust in the foreground
so John we need to resolve
yeah so the question is how do confident
re where do things stand the swirls do
they come from quantum fluctuations
stretched by inflationary expansion and
printing on the microwave background or
could it be something else yeah so the
answer the question as you put it
originally yeah are we certain that
these swirling patterns that we see on
the sky are actually coming from quantum
fluctuations that are telling us about
the inflationary theory the answer is no
we're not certain we the way that
science works is we always need
follow-up we need confirmation we need
more data what we said in March was that
we as we reported that pattern that our
telescope had observed over three years
and we had analyzed there were four
years of the data that we were very
confident looking at the statistics of
our data set that that pattern is not
there by random chance yes extremely
confident that there was a high
significance detection of --mode
polarization the swirling pattern on the
sky yeah and in fact that was the title
of the paper that we chose a section of
emote polarization at degree angular
scales so we did an analysis a thorough
analysis and we're looking forward to
rolling out all of the papers but the
analysis was actually complete and it's
in the result paper on the systematics
effects that we looked at in our
instrument to convince ourselves that
this was not a spurious effect that
arose some when our instrument and we
feel very confident of that statement I
think it's it's it's unlikely that there
is a systemic effect that we somehow
missed and all the cross-checks that
we've done in four years of analysis
yeah this data and we analyzed the data
with a great deal of skepticism when we
saw a signal starting to emerge from
this that was an unexpected signal for
our team this this swirling pattern had
a amplitude that was much larger than
frankly people were expecting to see one
so the the last question of what is the
interpretation of this signal a likely
interpretation what our team did is we
compared it
the signal and many ways to what the
expectations were for emission from our
galaxy we looked at radio emission
so not dust emission and we think we can
very confidently rule that out there are
a lot of discussions including from the
Princeton group about some contribution
from from radio emission synchrotron
emission we actually think that the the
data from that beautiful w map satellite
indicates that's really negligible so
you know we think that people should
look closely at that but we think people
can generally agree based on the data in
hand that that's not significant the
galactic dust there's a lot more
uncertainty so we said that when we
rolled out the the the result in March
but we looked at it in as many different
ways as we could with the data at hand
so we compared the amplitude of our
signal to the expected level given
historical projections of how much dust
power there ought to be and our patch
and I don't think that that's in dispute
that all of those projections were quite
a bit lower than the signal that we saw
the the the recent controversy I think
comes from the interpretation of what
new information has been brought to this
problem from the new Planck satellite
and data that they're only starting to
show us now on whether the the
polarization of this dust emission might
be higher than people have previously
assumed so we look when will that data
when will that Planck data be a well
we'd like to know I think we'd all like
to know we're very eager to see it but
so far the plunk I heard three weeks
actually I heard over breakfast yeah two
days ago I think you were there right
you were there I heard is that another
thing that would be great no we're very
eager to see what they have to to say
about the polarization in our region
because up until now what they've shown
us actually blanked out that region in
their published paper a few weeks ago
because they said that the uncertainties
were very high in their data set on what
the polarized dust emission looks like
there but we we looked at the data in
several other ways we looked at its
spatial distribution across our field
there was no evidence for the kinds of
unevenness that we would
to see from Glock to dust we looked at
the pattern of our B modes and it
doesn't match the pattern of any buddies
predicted pattern of dust polarization
and we looked at the evidence that we
have which right now is very limited in
the the the color or the different
frequency composition the signal that we
saw and although it's not a very
significant result it favors CMB and
disfavors dust and we reported all of
those things that I think we reported
them pretty pretty carefully and pretty
accurately and then that results in
March was that we concluded and many
people that looked at the data agreed
that the most likely interpretation is
that it's probably not dust that it's
probably dominated by inflation air
gravitational waves my favorite comments
at the time of our March 17th release
was from somebody who's not in our team
a theorist Mark kamionkowski he said it
quacks like a duck a lot of mine is
whatever uncertainty there is say within
a year but probably less there'll be
other data that will allow us to sort it
all that's right we're really excited a
beleaguered about the new data that's
going to be brought to bear from the
Planck satellite we're looking forward
to comparing our maps directly and doing
a joint analysis that's going to be
really powerful other groups including
Amber's are working really really hard
on producing more datasets and our own
team already has a lot more new data
that we're eager to get out there and
we're eager to see the answer we're
eager to see how the data breaks as much
as everybody else's yep great can I ask
you because you know this is this
announcement really created a huge
impact in the field and it had an impact
on people's lives and people's careers
on grants and the attitudes of the
public at large so it's a really you
know I think it made us a makes us
appreciate that the science we do really
has a huge impact and people are very
interested in it all over the world I
think you know but and since that
announcement there has been a lot of
discussion about what are possible
sources of ultra alternate explanations
for the same data set and I appreciate
what John said but you know now that
you've had this two months of experience
getting some feedback what is the in
March 17 there was a very clear strong
statement in the paper and in the
announcement that gravitational waves
had been observed and there were
statements about you know a lot of high
confidence levels
what would you say today what is the
right way to characterize it fair way to
characterize the situation as you see it
today I think the way that we
characterize the situation now is the
same way that we characterized it in
March and we did not say in the paper
that gravitational waves had been
observed we said the simplest and most
economical explanation for the data that
we were reporting was gravitational you
know I'm sorry but the your last line in
your paper was quite dramatic that the
error had apparently begun so clearly
that's right no no it's okay so listen I
think that we as scientists don't need
to dumb down the conversation for the
sake of the no let's want to make sure
you say qualifying it that's fine we
were careful to qualify it and and I
think it's important as we as we report
our scientific results and that those
get discussed in the public that we not
pretend that things are always black or
white that uncertainty is either zero or
a hundred percent so as we reported the
results and I think most of what I saw
written about our results was actually
on target in that sense that what was
being presented was evidence inflation
in favor of gravitational waves the
confidence level with what confidence
that would you express it well I
wouldn't have confidence should we often
express that in science in terms of
percentage confidence levels or Sigma or
you know and there's some statements
like that in a paper so you know looking
back at looking at the current situation
how you see it now but you say is the
same as seen then how would you express
it how would you best express it I think
that we express it by explaining the
different lines of argument that we have
in which the data right now don't match
up with the expectations from dust
combining those different lines of
arguments quantitatively is as difficult
as combining the lines of argument
favoring inflation versus alternatives
of inflation right now because their
model dependent statements really
what your preconceived notions are of
what a reasonable model of dust ought to
be in the absence of data so III think
you know there extrapolations from
regimes where we understand what the
uncertainties are to regimes where
people can actually disagree on what
reasonable guesses are so the best that
we can do in a situation like that as a
scientist is to lay out all of the
evidence and to allow people to discuss
it I think we did that very fairly so
Paul you also have expressed some
reservations even though you've played a
pivotal role in the development of the
inflationary theory with the theory
itself you've got only about about nine
minutes left but you want it do you want
to have a brief conversation about some
of those concerns and allow these
gentlemen over here - sure sure I'll try
to be brief so to help out yeah I think
there are I think the major concern
about the inflationary theory to me is
that we've learned over the last 30
years about inflation is it's
extraordinary flexibility in terms of
what it can produce we originally
thought of it as a theory which very
simply smooth flattens the universe and
leaves a very special spectrum of
perturbations behind and we've
discovered as it has at least three
different levels of flexibility that
allow you to vary what comes out
arbitrarily to begin with it turns out
that in its extraordinary results are
extraordinarily sensitive to the initial
conditions what exactly happens coming
out of the Big Bang we thought that
inflation would be robust and used to
you know automatically take over and
produce the bang as shown in your
beautiful movies we've learned that it
actually only works if you have rather
special initial conditions go away from
those special conditions and then the
output changes a second degree of
flexibility is you've been showing
different curves of this inflationary
field and there's you know some choices
and how you shape that that curve and as
you change that curve you change what
the predictions are Andrei has recently
written a paper in which he continuously
changes the parameters and continuously
changes the output showing that in fact
you can get a whole range of possible
predictions from the theory not
something specific
a whole range and then thirdly even if
you fix it those first two things I'd
love you to fix the initial conditions I
allow you to fix any particular shape
that you want then you end up with the
third issue which is the multiverse you
don't end up with a uniform universe
which has all the same properties
physical properties and cosmological
properties you end up with the universe
which is a multiverse which is a
patchwork of different patches which
span every conceivable cosmological
possibility so yes some are flat like
our universe like we were hoping for but
some are not in fact an infinite number
of these patches are not an infinite
number we'll have a beautiful simple
microwave background what we observe but
an infinite number will not etcetera
etcetera so in fact there's no since
every combination of things can happen
in this multiverse the there's no
prediction in such a theory there's so
much flexibility of theory which is to
say there's no test you can make of the
theory they would allow you to disprove
it now that's an important line when you
cross in science and you get to a point
and then a theory reaches a point where
you cannot conceive the test that would
rule it out then that theory crosses
from conventional science that we've
planted and practice over you know the
last hundred years into a different
realm and some people think that's ok
I'm conservative I think that from my
point of view that is you know takes you
past science into something that I would
call metaphysics and makes the theory
you know we would call scientifically
meaningless because you can't just prove
it all right Andre you've been
extraordinarily well behaved alan run to
any thoughts on that
nothing speechless that was good let me
start by commenting about Paul's most
recent comment about testability I think
anybody who's looked seriously at the
history of science realizes that the old
popper idea that theories are
falsifiable and you test them and test
them test them and then you discover an
experiment that doesn't work in the
medley occur then the theory is
falsified that's just not the way
science happen
rather science is an arena of competing
ideas and right now inflation is by far
the most widespread idea in cosmology
but if somebody comes up with another
idea
people will start comparing the two and
it's the preponderance of evidence that
ultimately determines which theory
survives which theories dies and so far
inflation just beautifully fits all of
the day that we have so it's it's
striving and as part of that confidence
come from the fact that the initial
calculations were done you know in a
single universe and you got amazing
agreement we've seen it between the data
and the theory so it was really a
prediction not a post diction that to me
feels impressive and it means that you
know I understand the issues that Paul's
raising Paula I've had a lot of
conversations we had a email exchange
that went on I don't know like a year
back and forth the battle I was looking
at the other day but it still feels that
this is gotta have some truth in it how
can you have that agreement is that part
of what drives your confidence oh yeah
absolutely absolutely and maybe I should
also clarify that inflation is not a
unique theory which is really part of
what Paul was talking about inflation is
really a general idea
you know we showed you these curves but
those are just typical curves so it is
true as Paul says that inflation is not
a unique theory but a class of theories
but nonetheless what we found so far is
that the simplest versions of inflation
are the ones that fit the data
beautifully the ones that were graphing
against on these graphs is that we're
showing you so we haven't had to add any
bells and whistles and look at extremely
exotic versions of inflation in order to
fit the data it just looks like a
beautiful fit - beautiful I would say to
have much chance of not being on the
right track yes I can
well not be playing directly because it
would be well lengthy I will just give
two citations I think that they're from
Churchill something well analogy between
democracy and inflation so democracy is
the worst possible form of God
except for all others that have been
tried and then another and then another
one that sometimes well people
eventually come to right decision only
after trying alternatives so that's
exactly what is going on right now you
know we're trying all the aterna give
all the attorneys for quite a while many
possibilities of alternative solution of
all existing problems have been proposed
in particular by Paul and I've studied
many of them and every single one which
I have been able to check everything
single on which I was able to check this
does not mean that every single one
because there are many but all of them
did not work in the end so this may be
just rule I was unlucky or maybe there
was something wrong in the way we're
testing but this pattern repeats and
repeats and repeats and every year we
have another alternative which is
actually encouraging on the other hand
yes it sounds like something very
strange is going on previously we were
in the hunt of the wild goose right okay
so now in the hunt of quacking duck
certainly there is a lot of progress but
what I can say independently of those
who is going to win who is going to lose
I just feel there's something in the
atmosphere something happening right now
that was 30 years ago all of us we're
developing one kind of theories we were
extremely exciting because we had this
feeling very similar to what you told
when talking about Einstein that Lord
could not make these mistakes etcetera
and I remember very vividly thinking for
myself I'm not a religious person but I
formulated that for me like that God
would make a stupid mistake missing an
opportunity like that and I just cannot
believe that he would do it so that was
theoretical and on the other hand at
that time it was kind of unbelievable
that we will come to experimental tests
of all of this although this wonderful
curves tested by Planck satellite it's
magnificent I remember how I was
boarding the airplane and coming to
United States from Geneva at the time
when this well perturbations have been
announced it and so my wife sent me a
message and I've been getting it on my
cell phone which I borrowed from my wife
yeah so she sent me
no non-gaussian e that is something
which everybody expected everybody
expected that right now 99% of an
inflationary theories will be dead
because one satellite is going to find
some specific not pleasant feature of
these perturbations and she said no
non-gaussian ET i am downloading 30
papers by plunk issued just right now as
i am boarding well and then I am reading
all of this during my flight two years
and I feel myself just I'm I was almost
actually I was physically crying at that
time I'm looking at this this was
totally spectacular now we're having
different set of evidences we do not
know yet in which direction it will all
go we know that one way or another
disagreement agreement we will
eventually reach some consensus about
this that's how science work is
sometimes painful it sometimes really
really hurt
okay but but on the other hand I found
myself all the time repeating what we
just I just noticed that this I'm
repeating when when you hear somebody
else say does not matter but when you
see here yourselves in fantastically
interesting then I go out home I return
back from the lectures i repeating well
not so fantastically interesting we're
living in the times when we're
stimulated about all of these
experimental discoveries and about
theoretical development into something
which sooner or later will be resolved
in something beautiful I am sure
I just can't congratulate everybody who
participates in this because it's such a
beauty contest whoever wins it it is a
big way
[Applause]
well thank you we uh we unfortunately
are at a time this has been a delightful
conversation I think the point you make
is a great man it is just astounding
that we can sit here and seriously talk
about what happened a trillionth of a
trillionth of a trillionth of a second
after the beginning we can talk about it
observational II theoretically I mean it
truly is the golden age of cosmology so
please join me in thanking
you
[Applause]